don't ever disrespect me it's the best
ever who did I just see acknowledge
your but they didn't know your name
there was oh Roseanne Roseanne have you
seen that one Colin he's so funny he
goes don't go disrespecting me what have
you heard him
he just goes don't come disrespect and
be looking like and he just has the
worst slams it's so funny who is it I
don't know he's on the internet but like
people walk away he goes don't don't
come looking oh I can't remember any of
his references they're so fresh but
he'll say like uh don't count don't come
disrespect and be looking like uh
where's Waldo they've got lost me
not knowing my name you owe me a hand
job now